[Music]
i just saw if you go to brett taylor the
chairman of twitter he just tweeted
we've agreed to a deal with elon musk oh
wow
wow so i guess i think i think saying
it's done is
fair yeah that's fair okay
um so 54 dollars a share
wow
so let me tell you something really
quick i i i this relates this is gonna
sound weird but it relates to what we're
talking about so do you know how a
combustible and combustible engine works
that's what i look like i know how a
combustible engine works
no so all right here's how a combustible
engine works so you've got this huge
block it's called an engine block it's
this big piece of metal imagine like a
rectangular cube that's about two and a
half feet long a foot wide and a foot
deep in depth understand okay when you
hear like a four cylinder six cylinder
eight cylinders 12 cylinders that's how
many cylinders they're going to drill
into that block of that that engine
block and so they you know how do you
know how big a cylinder is
uh well i've i've eaten pringles before
so i could sort of imagine
you're not far off so it's around like
it's like a can of coke almost a little
bit bigger but like just for the sake
we'll say it's like the size of a can of
coke okay and in in in in those
cylinders goes a piston which is
basically like you've drilled those
holes and like you've got something like
almost like a size of can of coke going
back and forth through those holes and
the way it works is you have a shaft
that connects to the pistons which turns
that up and down motion of the cylinders
going up and down into
motion that the engine can use but check
this out in order to make this all work
uh you have this thing called a spark
plug in each cylinder and then you have
this other device called a carburetor
and that mixes the perfect amount of
fuel and air into the cylinder and the
spark plug makes a small spark and
there's a miniature explosion in the
cylinder that for that creates so much
pressure that that's that piston is
moving up and down
does that all make sense
okay i fall i don't know why you're
telling me about this place i understand
it now listen
so
it gets even crazier
you know how you're driving and your car
will say like 6 000 rpms yeah sure that
means that those those pistons so these
pistons they it has to be airtight for
that explosion to be in that cylinder so
these pistons they're super tight into
that cylinder and they're it's creating
a lot of friction
when it says 6000 rpms that's 6 000
revolutions per minute and 6 000 means
you're like driving pretty fast but not
crazy fast that means those pistons are
moving up and down 100 to 150 times per
second
wow
and you have oil in your car because
those pistons are rubbing against metal
and it needs oil otherwise if you leave
it without oil they're moving so fast
it's going to fuse together and
basically weld the piston to the
cylinder
geez okay okay the reason i'm breaking
this up
listen i can't wait to hear it and and
because i just watched a youtube video
about it and i it's still fresh in my
mind that's why i had to say it you did
no it sounds like you just like wait a
different way i was thinking about this
and that and basically and then the
output of all this is like uh carbon ax
so it's like a it's like a gas and
there's fumes and there's oil and
there's liquid there's all types of
fluid and then there's a transmission
which is like totally even crazier
sometimes
the fact that this was invented in the
early 1900s and it's still the
technology that we have exploited and
made so good we've made this so good
that these pistons can move for a
million miles basically they're going to
go up and down like a trillion plus
times
we have pushed that so far to the edge
it's pretty phenomenal what we've done
and it's such a shitty technology it was
good for what it was and then elon musk
comes along and i was like well he
wasn't the first one to do it but he did
a really good job of it he's like this
this electric engine actually all we're
gonna use is a battery and one motor
that's all it takes and this motor is
like just literally like three parts
like there's very few parts whereas with
the combustible engine there's like a
thousand parts and not only is it
simpler in terms of maintenance there's
basically no maintenance it's far better
so a really fast car i have i own a car
that's considered incredibly fast and
it's quite expensive and it goes zero to
16.
yeah well it's considered fast it goes
zero to 60 in three seconds a tesla that
costs 40 grand will crush that can crush
that and go so it's faster in every
sense of the word it doesn't break and i
kind of had one of these moments where i
was like i wasn't actually high but it
was like one of those high moments where
you're like
unfortunately you just decided to have
high thoughts without you yeah i had
high thoughts i was like dude we've been
doing this combustible engine thing for
like 130 years now
and then along comes a couple people
who's like no no we're gonna do this
total opposite way so instead of making
an engine that just like is it somehow
has more cylinders or it's more smooth
something we're gonna do something
totally opposite and
it's like levels above in terms of
quality and i find that thought to be
absolutely amazing and it just turns out
he just bought twitter today so maybe
something crazier is going to happen
there i actually don't think it will but
maybe but isn't that wild to think that
like we can literally i don't know how
many people have existed since 1910
billions and billions and billions of
people we've all been doing it one way
and then along comes a very small group
of people let's say tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of people who said
no no this is the way to do it
and it changes everything and i find
that to be amazing i i agree that is
amazing a couple thoughts that came up
while you were saying this
first of all thank you for the engine
lesson
does that make sense did i 10 more man
because i i know how to describe this
did i explain to you do you understand
how the engine works now a little bit a
little bit yeah i feel like i feel like
i'm at that perfect point where i feel
like i know because i don't know what i
don't know
uh if you've ever seen the
dunning-kruger effect exactly
what you should know the takeaway here
is that it's very very very crude you've
got these like metal one metals like
rubbing against each other and creating
it's just messy it's smelly it's it's
crude well i just did something today
that reminded that what you're talking
about reminds me of this which is uh
i went to the doctor i went to the eye
doctor i had a eye appointment and uh
not because i wanted to i was like just
give me my goddamn contacts and they're
like nope you gotta come in it's uh
that's two years old now we gotta do the
whole we're gonna we're gonna do the
thing where we blow puff air on your
eyeball it's like oh my god what is that
even for i don't know but i went in i
decided to have a little bit of a
different attitude so i got real curious
when i went in this time i'm talking to
the doctor i'm asking a bunch of
questions she runs this other test on me
where she takes a picture of my eye
and then she shows it to me on a screen
and i don't have you ever seen like the
inside of an eye it's disgusting it's
[__] wild dude this is crazy she's
like okay so like this is the nerve in
the back of your eye
that's what's sending all these signals
your eyes just getting light from
everywhere and your brain is this
nervous the thing transmitting to your
brain all these i these this light
signals and your brain is piecing
together sometimes the construction of
the world yeah it's amazing looking
these are all the blood vessels that's
like keeping your eye alive and when you
whenever i see how the body works
i just sort of marvel in it i'm like
i don't have to think but my liver knows
how to like detoxify my body you know i
don't have to think my heart will just
keep beating reliably or else i'll die
but like luckily it's on autopilot and
um in fact it's on so much on autopilot
i couldn't stop it if i wanted to and so
it's like the way that the human body
works is just like a true marvel
and
so today's my birthday and seeing that
oh i forgot to tell you on air happy
birthday thank you appreciate we all we
talked earlier on the phone but the
thing that amazes me it's like the best
thing to do on your birthday is to go
just like get a scan of your body and
just be like wow
you know the human body is like an
absolutely incredible machine that just
works in like the same way i don't know
how an engine works i don't know how my
liver works i don't know how my kidney
works i don't know how my lungs work i
don't know how any of this [__] works
but it does work and just the fact that
it does is kind of amazing to me and
just seeing my eyeball my retina and
like the nerves the blood vessels in my
eye was just a reminder of like
uh it's like it's like a humble humbling
feeling right it's like the humility of
how you don't even have control of your
own body let alone
the world and all these other things
that are going on so i really
appreciated that that's the first thing
second thing
i wrote this down the other day
for the podcast but i never knew how
by the way are you wearing a mighty
ducks jersey
yeah dudes my birthday i'm feeling like
a mighty duck right now oh my god that's
awesome
the older i get the more i need to
behave like a child right like that's
that's kind of the game plan is get more
childlike as i grow not more adult-like
so
i wrote this down i wrote
vocal minority mobile minority and i
didn't i wrote this one like a month ago
and i was like it might come up at some
point the podcast and what you just said
about elon about basically a very small
number of people changing the way that
things work is a great example of this
so and it's not like he's the guy like
that he was like you know we can't say
that like elon came up with this we
could just say that there's probably a
lot of people came to the same
conclusion he just was had the strongest
will and is the is the is the person who
we give a lot of credit to by the way
have you seen what he's been saying
lately about this like origin story of
tesla have you seen this controversy no
does he say that he's the founder no no
so he so he so the
what happened was tesla started about a
year before elon
invested in it and so now he's seen as
the he's basically seen as the ceo the
fountain he is the ceo he's also kind of
like the founder you don't really hear
about these other guys who started these
two guys that were that were starting it
i think and he is kind of the founder
when you think about it like it's like
literally the eighth largest company in
the world and at the time it was worth
like 10 million dollars like what's the
difference
exactly and so but the guys who started
it
have like basically just made it kind of
like their mission so so the the elon
there's a there's a group of people that
are like anti-elon they're a vocal
minority against elon and they'll say
like things like
elon didn't create tesla he just you
know invested in it and like takes all
the credit for it basically
and um and that one of the original guys
also really has like made it his mission
to keep telling people how much he how
he was the founder of tesla not not elon
musk uh and elon sort of like come out
recently he said something the other day
in his interview he goes
the biggest mistake they go what's the
biggest regret you have this biggest
regret you have or mistake you've made
bad decision you've made he goes
well certainly the worst business
decision i made was
um
not deciding to just like start tesla on
my own with me and jb like i guess the
guy he started it with like guy he feels
like was his co-founder in it and like
basically buying the existing company
and then building from there versus just
doing it on his own he's like certainly
that was the worst decision i think
because financially that guy owns shares
of what's now a trillion dollar company
and then the second thing is that that
guy basically has made it his crusade to
be like
f elon musk i'm the founder of tesla
until you know how much does that guy
own
i don't know the exact percentage maybe
maybe uh somebody john they could look
it up while we're while we were talking
but like
but that guy basically uh
there's like i think his name is
there's two guys um yeah martin and
somebody else and i think that's his
name so they
one of the things that they say is like
um you know we created tesla and then
elon has come out and been like tesla
was nothing there was no product they
were basically like it was a shell of a
company there was no uh it was like you
know pre-launch pre-everything i
invested six and a half million dollars
i think he invested in the first round
knowing also that i'd have to invest way
more after that took a chairman role and
then like basically
he had the guy from who designed
spacex's logo designed the tesla
branding and like you know he's like i
guess he created it was a it was an
inactive company it was what he what he
had said um he i think he tweeted
something like this out that it was like
a dormant company or something like that
and so there's like some controversy
around that actual founding of it but
yeah how is that his biggest mistake
that doesn't seem like that big like it
worked out fine and also one could argue
maybe it was worth it just with the name
yeah exactly just for the exactly just
for the name i guess his take would sort
of be like the company was just going to
die if he didn't invest in right i think
he was the only investor at that time
um
so anyways uh okay back to my vocal
minority so there's
we see this a lot on twitter and other
places where there's a vocal minority
this is what people call cancel culture
this is what people will call like
sort of the haters or the naysayers
online there's a small group of people
that are sort of unhappy about anything
that happens and they'll they'll be
unhappy that twitter's being bought by
elon musk they'll be unhappy that he's a
billionaire they'll be unhappy that
tesla they'll say that tesla's cars yes
they're electric but but what power is
the electricity it's coal you know they
just always have something to say so
there's a vocal minority and i think one
of the biggest skills in today for any
business person is to correctly identify
like
a vocal majority versus a
vocal minority if you just constantly
let the vocal mind already sway your
thinking you're letting like you know
the bottom one or two percent of people
sway your decision making just because
they're very loud about it but then the
the other so you i think you want to
overlook them but what you don't want to
overlook is what's called what i call a
mobile minority so a mobile minority is
a group of people who decide to actually
like take their business and walk
elsewhere
or they take their lifestyle and they
just change it so it's like you know if
you're a
safeway
but all of a sudden there's like a small
group of like sort of hippie people that
are like buying this like all-natural
produce right and they're shopping at
this place called whole foods market in
austin and that's only got one one
location two locations but like all of
their spend now goes to this or you see
people that are like you know
um you know
people on netflix or whatever people who
are subscribed to netflix but all of a
sudden they start to instead spend all
their time on tick tock and youtube and
it's like
they've actually voted with their feet
or
actually
i mean even a
a different
non-business example i was just reading
about martin luther king and rosa parks
and when the whole rosa parks thing
happened the black folks were like no
we're uh you know we're not taking that
and originally like well that only makes
a certain amount of our population it's
no big deal that it like goes on for
like two weeks you're like all right
something's happening and it's happening
in san francisco right now like a mobile
minority of group of people have left
san francisco taken their business
elsewhere it's a very small group of
people some of them were loud about it
saying oh i'm leaving because i have
this this and this beef with san
francisco most of them were just
frustrated like i'm going awesome going
to miami i'm going elsewhere i'm going
where i will be treated better well i
will be tax less and get more from my
government
and um and those mobile minorities are
actually ones you want to listen to if
whether you're a politician or you're an
entrepreneur
it's like we we talk about this a lot
right dude there's just subreddit that's
getting really popular and it's like oh
yeah it's only 50 000 people but it's
like wow 50 000 people have chosen this
lifestyle of like you know either
anti-work or over-employed or they're
tracking their like fitness and their
sleep at this like maniacal way it's
like yeah that actually is
something you really want to pay
attention to and it's a great place to
start a business is when you notice a
mobile minority um and it's also like a
really important thing to notice as a
leader of either a city or a company to
notice
huh how come all these developers are
like you know going to this weird like
web 3 crypto thing like what's that
about it's like yeah it's not everybody
but like wow like
you know 10 of our smartest people all
left to go do this thing
they took a pay cut to go do this thing
i thought i think i should probably pay
attention to that and so uh so i wanted
to point this out which is
ignore the vocal minority
and pay extra attention to the mobile
minority that doesn't mean there's
another side to this it doesn't mean
they're right
so for example or that like what they're
doing like
i i i agree with you i would also
challenge myself to find examples where
there is that's a great what's it what's
it called uh
mobile minority yeah that's a good
that's a good one trademark that we're
trademarking that that's in my first
million originals so like there's people
like like for example day trading
amongst young people has gotten
incredibly popular i don't think the
majority of people do it but i think
there are a lot of people do it they're
very loud and they're betting a lot and
i think that's horribly stupid
yeah yeah i'm not saying it's always a
good thing right it might be people
vaping and it's like wait a minute
like
10 of teenagers are vaping now it's like
i'm not saying it's always healthy but
i'm saying it is almost always worth
paying attention to this sort of like
silent and mobile minority versus
like i think it's worth paying attention
to whereas i think the vocal minority is
almost always worth ignoring
you want to talk a few examples off the
top of our head a few examples of those
groups of people
um well you get a couple i think i'm
gonna give a few more yeah give give me
give me something i'm just gonna write
off a few
so
things that i'm noticing based off
reddit and my interest um people who
don't wanna buy off amazon because they
don't want to have to worry about
throwing away the packaging yes number
two people who want to use reusable
um packaging so like a ziploc bag that
you'll pay 20 for one bag but you can
use it over and over and over and over
again number three people who don't want
to eat out of plastic
uh let's see number four i have another
one that's related to that so my wife's
vegan and so we're anything we do has to
be compatible with a vegan lifestyle and
you'd be shocked how much
how much is uh not compatible so like
okay you think about food i think food
is where most people go but like leather
is the other huge one right so like
we're about to buy a car or uh like she
wants to buy like a fancy purse or
something like that she's like she is
ready to go to whatever louis vuitton or
whatever and drop
five grand six grand whatever it is but
uh she won't she won't do it because
it's all leather and so she's like i
can't believe these luxury companies
don't make one
non like non animal based product like
they don't make one bag like even they
would get all the v all the vegan people
want to buy luxury like go to whichever
brand makes it like all of the big ones
gucci prada whatever
and um and they just don't they don't
make it or if they do they like they'll
make the bag but not the not the handle
or the strap and she's like well that's
the thing like if you cared about this
you care about this and so we see that
with like car too like tesla has all
like um vegan leather and they're one of
the few car makers that like just lead
with that it's like these little things
that like again super easy to overlook i
would you know i would totally
understand saying look we're not gonna
change our product line for this one or
two percent but as that one or two
percent gets big enough like it i don't
know how much the sort of vegan
population is now in america but like
let's say it's two or three percent
that's of a base of 300 million people
and those are people who like they don't
just kind of care about it they really
care about it and so they're the they're
the mobile minority and the vocal
minority
exactly they use they do action and they
talk a lot
yeah exactly
so like you know you make a chocolate
and make a cheese make a car leather
whatever so that's an example where i've
seen a lot of like wallet share go to
the one brand that just cares about it
what else is there so i think there's
also uh when i read the tick tock
comments there's so many people that
when they post videos of people from the
early 2000s or when i was in high school
2008 and they say oh wow look no one's
on a cell phone they must be so happy
so i think there's going to be a mobile
minority of people who actually don't
want smartphones the the disconnect
digital detox population yeah there's
also a group of that that's uh like vr
like absolute vr nerds so uh they don't
talk much in fact most of the dialogue
around vr is how it's not here yet or
it's not going to happen
there's a small number of people
that spend an absurd amount of time in
vr they work in their vr like i don't
know if i i think i sent you this take
talk of there's a guy who
says he's spending 24 7 in vr
and uh he literally wakes up puts the
headset on and he spends his whole day
like that and he even goes to sleep in
vr and then he like you know the headset
falls off or whenever he sleeps it's
like some some nut but
close your eyes and imagine this guy
yeah like
the beard touches the chest hair so
[Laughter]
there is no line yeah
we need strong borders
he has a rack just for fedoras
so
basically like you know there's some
people that are spending a lot of time
there but you know i don't know if
that's like a big one yet but like i'm
just sort of like brainstorming off top
of my head you know people who really
really care about certain things and i
think you'll see this with pet stuff i
think you see this with like in like
house stuff that's going on like if
you're in the gym business right now you
know the mobile minority through covet
has been like home gyms like those
people are never coming back once they
put like thousands of dollars of gym
equipment in their garage or their room
you know bedroom in their house like
they're not coming back into the gym
industry right so it's a mobile minority
they have voted with their feet and now
they're going down a different path a
different lifestyle yeah i think that
that's a really good term i'm on board
with mobile minority but what does it
have to do with engines
uh well no it's about like the few
people that go and actually like they do
something different right so like you
were saying like elon and the sort of
the electric car yeah yeah you know that
that's a small number of people who just
like
took a sharp left turn and decided nope
we're gonna like we're gonna get off the
oil and gas system we're gonna like not
have a combustible edge of car we're not
gonna buy from any of these brands like
we're just gonna go fully electric do
you think but here's the thing i've been
that i think about when i think about
him and people like him is i think okay
so obviously he's right so this tesla
thing like it's right but
it didn't seem that way all the time it
seemed like the total opposite and
there's moments in my life where i'm
like i firmly believe that this is the
future like i firmly believe that many
homes are going to be bought online uh
like that's an example but along the way
i have so many doubts or i'm like ah
screw it and so what i would like to
know is i wonder how
he cuz he doesn't give off that
appearance like he ever has doubt he's
like no no like this surely this makes
sense but then he does say all the time
he's like i think we're going to go
bankrupt but that doesn't mean he thinks
that his idea is wrong he just thinks
that maybe like they're just going to
run out of money because they didn't
have enough runway and so do you think
that someone like him or a lot of these
other people like that that there is
self-doubt or uh or what
you move straight to the end now um if
you listen to him talk he actually says
three things so he says
they're like how did you decide to do
this no car company had ever no american
car company had been made since jeep
like 90 years ago or something like that
uh nobody had ever made an electric car
you know that was popular you know a
fully electric
car nobody had ever
you know started a rocket company a
private rocket company all this stuff
and he basically just said they're like
so how did you decide to do it and he's
like
well i agreed like the probability of
success was low
but it was worth doing so i just did it
you know like he's basically like i
thought it was worth doing humanity
needs this so it's worth doing certainly
probability of success is low certainly
and then uh he said one other thing
which was like you know
did you ever think about giving up but
he's like he had said and that likes
free interview
it is not in my nature and like i think
it i think so if you take those three
things like he doesn't decide to do it
because he thinks it's gonna work in
fact he decides to do it because he
thinks it's worth doing
he agreed that the probability of
success was low but not impossible
and he just decided that he's not going
to give up that's not in his nature so
you combine those three things well
doubt has very little place right it's
like no i've accurate i've i've taken
into account the low probability of
success
and then i'm not going to quit
so and i just already decided it's worth
doing so we're in that you know doubt
can't live in that home that's a
two-bedroom home and doubt doesn't have
a room in that in that house so so i
think that's how that's the psychology
i've seen not knowing the guy uh just
from his interviews but i don't i'm not
sure if that's the the entire reality
even though he said that and here's why
uh did you ever pay attention to boxing
in the 90s with mike tyson
sure yeah all right so mike tyson came
on the boxing scene when he was 19 and
he was like the man until he was like in
his early-ish 30s and when he walked out
of the ring uh walked out in the stadium
up to the ring he was famous because he
wore black
shorts he wore black socks and black
shoes and he would come out with no
shirt on with his gloves already tight
and everything and he would just as if
he's just ready to roll typically that's
not how they do it and he was already
sweating and he didn't have a noise or
sorry he didn't have a sound uh a song
that he came out to he came out to a
noise it was just
that was the noise and it was just all
his whole thing was about being
frightening he's like i am i'm a tiger
i'm a beast i am here to kill and yeah
and he would say things like that like
i'm going to take out your heart and eat
it yeah and he'd be like you know
you know
what was the great interview where he's
like he goes uh he goes i'm gonna
defense is impregnable my
my will is unstoppable praise be to
allah he goes and he goes i'm gonna eat
his heart i'm gonna eat his children
he goes i'm alexander the great he ain't
no alexander the great i'm alexander the
great yeah like this is
total bravado yeah
scary guy
and when he would look at you in the eye
you're like this guy's gonna this guy's
gonna murder him he's not just going to
beat him up he's out to kill him and i
would watch interviews with him now that
he's older and he doesn't have to act
that way anymore he goes
he goes people thought i was so deadly
he goes i was deadly but i was so afraid
the reason i acted like that was because
my the the reality was my fear was the
total opposite end and i had to act that
way because he was i was so afraid and
i've heard a bunch of ufc fighters that
i like like donald cerrone and chael son
and bill go every michael bisping and
they say every single time i'm backstage
and i think to myself why did i do this
why didn't i quit i don't want to do
this i'm afraid i am so scared to do
this in reality this guy i'm talking
about michael bisping he's got the
biggest mouth of everyone he talks the
most trash and when i heard these
fighters start saying this stuff i was
like oh they're like
you're you're you are the toughest guy
on earth right now but even the toughest
guy on earth is scared yeah
they they go into a cage fight with
another guy who's trying to kill them in
their underwear in front of millions of
people like and after talking mad [__]
right so it is one of the like you know
most vulnerable positions you could put
yourself into so that's why it's great
to kind of like learn from them and hear
their hear their uh you know their
thought process i think that's true
somebody had said this about elon they
uh i think it was
uh maybe jurviston like one there's an
investor who invested in tesla and
spacex um and i believe has never sold a
share and never said he never plans to
sell a share of any of those companies
and so you know
this guy's got the best returns ever
because all his bets were just bad on
elon and um he said like he said
something like you know elon is just he
goes he's a normal guy but the fear gene
got removed
and uh like you know in in his dna that
the fear gene got removed i actually
think that
it's not that like nobody's that um
everybody has you know fears and
you know the the extent to which you are
fearless is the extent to which you
learn how to dance with your own fears
right so like those ufc fighters they
feel the fear but they learn how to cope
with it and for mike it was getting into
this like you know primal state of mind
saying certain things and just walking
to the to the thing to that sound and
like that's how he was able to like
dance with that fear and so i'm sure
that somebody like an elon musk even
though they have fears of you know
failure humiliation you know
three rockets blow up for spacex you
know just like explode and now you're
you basically put all your money in and
you you have enough for one more launch
and that's it you had to rush and do one
more launch
yeah i don't think he was sitting there
you know with a resting heart rate of 46
you know i think he was feeling
something at that time you could see it
in the videos uh the relief when it
happens but he learned to dance he
learned to deal with it so i think you
know that's that's the difference
between people who seem you know totally
brave or fearless is like they have just
learned to deal with fear better than
the person who lets the fear slow them
down or stop them are any of your
closest successful friends autistic or
have aspergers
sure do seem like it sometimes
that's closest friends to be honest
because uh
yeah i like to get along i end up
getting along with people a little more
outgoing extroverted and easier to get
along with but i've gotta you have a
couple i know i've got a couple and
you're friends with them as well and
i've got a couple and what i've noticed
i've got one in particular who i think
you know i'm talking about yeah and very
very very successful and he just doesn't
he approaches things far more logically
and i'm like well name this will never
well brad i'm making up well brad this
will never work he's like well why not
why won't it work like you know you see
on this excel spreadsheet this math adds
up to where it does work like well but
like who's going to believe you who's
going to have faith in you how are you
going to do it well why wouldn't they
you know what i mean
sometimes i wonder is that just a couple
of my friends who are like that or if
there is something and elon has studied
as asperger's is there something in
there where they like um
where it's like you know it's supposed
to be kind of like a handicap in reality
it's the exact opposite it's like a
superpower
well i played poker for a long time and
you see this with poker players too they
uh some of the best poker players are
some of the sort of like
you know aspergery type of mannerisms
you don't they're
extremely intelligent
but they have an emotional
coolness
which allows them to be
rational under pressure
not get as easily tilted as an emotional
player would be
they can play with huge sums of money
and not change the way they play it's
all just chips to them it's a game to
them
um
and they also have the ability to focus
for very very long periods of time
longer than you know i would say the
average person
and so you know there's some definite
superpowers if you have that you know
that brain wiring which is i don't know
what i'm just using these terms i don't
actually have any idea what the clinical
like you know definition of these terms
is but i'm just
i'm sort of reverse defining it as a
person who has those traits the ability
to have a maniacal focus the ability to
stay calm and sort of uh emotionally
cool despite what's going on
um you know
highly highly intelligent with
especially with math probability and
statistics and um
and so they you know they're winners
dude i've seen it just so many times
that that is a whenever i sit down
against that opponent that is the person
i'm trying to stay out of pots with i'm
not trying to compete against them when
i go play poker all right let me let me
tell you something interesting that
happened to me you said you went to the
doctor i went i had to get some like i
bought a vehicle and i had to get it
like registered you know you got to get
your registered and title and all that
stuff dmv stuff dude it sucks all right
so this is like some people listening
this is so obvious do you know that
there's third parties that will do this
for you
i've heard about this actually some guy
told me he's like yeah as like dmv sucks
he's like oh dude my buddy and i opened
up like a like an alt like an
alternative dmv in like you know in the
dc area it's amazing we do like three
million dollars here i was like what
dude open your own dmv like
i never looked into it what is the rules
all right so like i went to the dmv and
like i didn't know you had to have an
appointment to go and the woman working
there was like hey just go to this thing
called fry title or something like that
and so i just looked it up on yelp and
it was like 20 minutes away and i went
out there and there was a line out the
door but i got in and out and so
basically it's a
crappy building and a strip mall exactly
like you'd think and uh like next to
like a marshalls or something like that
and you can go there to get license
plates you can get their title transfer
specialty plates temporary permits you
can register your car there um and it
basically has like a lot of the stuff
that you would mostly do at a dmv you
can't do some things but mostly
everything that you do and the way that
you get it is you do a partnership with
the motor vehicle department of every
single state and you got to go through
this like application process that i
don't think is that hard because when i
was there i was talking to the owner and
he was like a young he was like a 24
year old like it was like an
unsophisticated smart but
unsophisticated guy and he was like yeah
i just applied and i was like do you
guys always have a line because there's
signs everywhere that says we know we uh
line
no new line people at four because we
close at five so because so basically
like i was like are you guys this busy
all the time he goes constantly i'm like
are you kidding me and he's like yeah
and i was like well how do you guys make
money he's like well we're gonna charge
you like 50 to 100 right right here for
this fee and i was like oh no brainer
like because the the dmv here in austin
i've got to wait four months or
something for an appointment something
crazy
and it was a crazy service and i started
looking into it and there's a few
companies that are in the space you know
dmv
dot org
no you know her at dmv.org it's like if
you google like what paperwork do i need
in order to uh
uh in order to get a license in in in
delaware like it'll tell you like what
to bring uh so that that's out there but
there's basically all these places that
i've seen do this they're just like mom
and pop like hole-in-the-wall stores
and they are constantly packed it was
crazy fascinating
i did hear something which was like uh
that guy that i was talking about
something did end up happening or they
cracked down or like they lost their
thing or like
once i don't know what happened but
something did something bad did happen
this was years ago so i don't remember
but let me tell you about two other
businesses that are very similar have
you heard of acebel
what's aceable
acebel it's in texas it's you're gonna
love this business so just go to like
asable.com you sound like george
zimmerman like you're you're gonna like
the way you look i guarantee you yeah
you're gonna like this business yeah
you're gonna like this like i guarantee
it
[Laughter]
men's bro house here
so it's basically driver's ed online and
they also do um like if you get a ticket
you have to go to like corrective
driving school or whatever oh my god
kill it
so they're like an officially licensed
um like vendor for this driver's ed at
these like these courses or whatever
they absolutely crushed they
bootstrapped for a while i think now
they've raised like 100 million dollars
these guys are absolutely crushing it
i've seen their revenue once before back
way back when i looked into this
and um
they started with like you know like a
32 hour driver's ed course or whatever
and they could do i think they could do
it in like
36 states out of that of the total or
whatever and so um they said they have
13 million like people have gone through
it and they also do
realtors licenses which is like one of
people trying to get their broker's
license oh and so that's like another
like
this is such a this is an amazing
business this is like a uh like 10 out
of 10 under the radar business that just
crushes it and they crush it due to like
kind of like regulatory lock-in
and um that they're one of like the only
officially approved people that could do
this they just crushed it with google
ads because people would search for you
know driver's ed free driver's ed online
get my broker's license blah blah blah
and um
there wasn't a ton of competition i
don't think early on and they just made
a ton of money and so i i this is i'm
pretty sure a billion dollar company at
this point oh for sure you know just
doing this this guy's name is blake who
started another blake uh blake myoski
the guy who started toms shoes his first
business was an online driver's ed
business and he said he crushed it oh
wow i didn't know that that's yeah when
i read his biography like give away
shoes or i don't know it was one of
those it was like about giving away buy
a pair give a pair yeah and uh anyway
this business kills it what's the other
one so the other one so i was about to
take a trip with my family and i was
like oh we don't have like passports for
the kids
uh so i was like oh let me get like we
don't have the birth certificates
because you if you just like when a
baby's born they don't give you a
certificate it's like
oh you want a birth certificate like
you know
they roll out like a candy crush map
it's like do these six steps and like
jump over all these hurdles to like get
your kid's birth certificate so it's
like you gotta like do this thing and go
to the city whatever so i was like oh
geez i don't want to do all that and so
i just searched like get birth
certificate online fast and the san
francisco or whatever like the bay area
you know whatever like you know
the walnut creek like official birth
certificate thing i was like yeah you
can like either mail in this stuff or
go to our partner vital check final
check we'll do it
and i was like oh here's another one and
sure enough i see it vital if you go to
vitalchek.com
there's so many copycats there's
yourvitalcheck.com and check is spelled
c-h-e-k that's how you know these
businesses crush the number of copycats
that pop up
so
it's an official california birth
certificate that you can get online
um you know it's government endorsed so
hundreds of government agencies
nationwide exclusively trust vital
checks so they've got they basically cut
deals with those vendors
and whatever you go on here you pay i
don't know it's like whatever 99 bucks
or something per birth certificate you
follow this form and it's done and it's
like you kind of have to do this like
it's like a mandatory thing it's like a
dmv thing it's like
customers aren't just like choosing to
go get certified they have to get
certified and so that's why i love
acebol that's why i love your dmv one
that's why i love this vital check thing
because it's super crazy you have to do
it to comply
and you can build these kind of like
third party things and i i sent this to
xavier and sieva our buddies with
enduring ventures i was like dude this
is a beautiful business to buy right
like because they're going and trying to
buy these businesses that are like just
cash flowing profitable businesses that
have defensibility um and can be maybe
improved by like rolling up multiple or
like centralizing the the back office
and the the other the other like red
flat not red what's whatever the
opposite of a red flag is positive flag
a green flag that my like red flag of
like this is a killer company is going
off because it's a website
it's an ugly website with a lot of
traffic and it doesn't say who the
founder is on the about page it says
we've been in business since 1992 and we
do this this and this and like i can't
find like a guy on twitter talking about
it i'm like okay so you just so see eva
got back to me he goes it looks he's
like i dug in it looks like it's owned
by a uk public company
called the lexus nexus
relics i think relics which owns lexicon
it's like a multi-billion dollar it's
like the most uh i believe relic is the
most profitable company in the world in
terms of margins so uh they they they
own another the big thing they own is do
you know how scientific journaling uh
like publishing works basically like
sure these like doctors and stuff come
up with these these amazing insights and
scientific journals like yeah we'll give
you 500 for your article
and like
that's all they get paid and every
university like has paid money to get
access to these journals and so they
make like four billion in revenue and
like three billion in profit or
something like that
wow yeah it's a it looks like it's a 50
billion dollar
a little more than a 50 billion dollar
company what's the can you see what the
profit like what the income is they
probably have done 33 000 employees uh i
can pull up i mean i can pull up it's
like though i think it's one of the uh
how do you spell it
rel x
yeah i think it's uh dude how do you
know about this this is another sampard
special right here just
knowing that of some random british
public company that owns scientific
journaling companies and is the most
profitable company in the world
how the hell did you know that
i i i
confirmed that it's if it's not the most
it's one of the most and i knew about it
because a uh i i had friends in the in
the journal uh who were like getting
their phds and i was they were telling
me how it works so i'm like oh that's a
racket like you you don't understand but
you're lucky
like it's like you know dentists and
stuff publishing stuff on like teeth
like they don't understand like how
margin works and i'm like they're paying
you 500 for that you don't understand
[__]
uh so they're just getting ripped off so
i knew right away and second when we
were launching the hustle i love
database businesses and i researched
database businesses like crazy and i
came across this company because they
own
um
they own they own lexus nexus which is
which is like a total conglomerate
legal records and documents
they own patent site which is um
it has a patent asset index of 135
million patent documents
law 360
lex lex machina which is like 88 million
whatever things there's just ton of
database businesses in there illegal law
360 is like it's kind of like
uh the hustle but for lawyers i mean of
course they were first so we were like
them for not lawyers but it was
basically a daily newsletter for lawyers
yeah elon's like me for billionaires
you know
the problem
that i have about elon is he just rips
off my style like i was using twitter
way before like i was popular on twitter
first yeah i do memes he does memes
right like he's kind of like the
poster he's impulsive but i am to
podcast he is to money
[Laughter]
money business and innovation
dating celebrities
[Laughter]
doesn't have a podcast though yeah dude
i was thinking of uh jake paul we had
jake paul on the podcast and i was like
thinking about it i was like if i got
into an argument with that guy he could
just be like
well i'm richer than you and i'd be like
well i could kick your ass he's like you
know i can kick your ass i'd be like oh
yeah you can't he's like well i'd be
like well and i'd be like well i'm
famous and he would be like well i'm i'm
more famous so i'm like oh you're like
like everything better like every like
whatever like i think of these people
like i'm like oh like you are everything
i do you are that but better i have
nothing i could say to you in a fight
like you're just gonna win this argument
every single time i'm screwed so
sometimes i ask myself what can i
possibly say
and so like that's sometimes i think
about elon no that's when you have to uh
swerve into the virtue signaling and be
like well i'm just i don't chase money
and fame
yeah
so yeah you're way more famous and rich
yeah well i wouldn't trade lies with you
you're must be invisible i i have one
thing you'll never have enough and
[Music]
that's the moral high ground you can
always take on somebody better than you
he's elon's like the sam parr of but
just have money
[Laughter]
good episode see you later
[Music]
you